y en directo América ahora es momento de
hablar de economía por ello me acompañan
el estudio mi compañero Jorge Hurtado
Jorge bienvenido vamos a iniciar en
Estados Unidos porque continúa
claramente el nerviosismo en el entorno
al sector financiero hoy el foco está
puesto en First Republic Bank por qué
bueno no es casualidad este banco tuvo
la tercera tasa más alta de depósitos no
asegurados entre los bancos de Estados
Unidos solamente detrás de silicon y
designaturang según una nota de Raymond
esto hizo pensar a muchos que el
siguiente en la lista de quiebra sería
este banco pero lo que otro grupo de
bancos anunciaron también fue un rescate
para el mismo Qué bancos lo rescataron Y
por qué se lo preguntamos a nuestra
corresponsal en Nueva York mamen sala
el principal motivo de este movimiento
ha sido Mostrar un sistema financiero
fuerte que respalda al pequeño y al
mediano banco y sobre todo que el
republican Bank no siguiera el mismo
camino que silicon Valley Bank o que
signaturbank aquí en Nueva York que es
lo que ha ocurrido bien los 11 bancos 11
bancos grandes bancos norteamericanos
han salido al rescate de First Bank que
estaba viendo cómo se quedaba sin
liquidez sus acciones a caían en picado
hasta un 70% Y ante esta situación han
salido a su rescate Con una inyección ha
sido una noticia que hemos conocido hoy
de 30.000 millones de dólares en
liquidez para estabilizarlo Cuáles son
los bancos que van a ayudar en esta
estabilización Pues bien el GP Morgan y
el banco famerica que ya han dicho que
ofrecerán una inyección de 5 mil
millones de dólares el city bank
seguramente también es una información
Que de momento no está confirmada pero
algunos periódicos nacionales apuntan a
ello y el goldman sachs y Morgan staline
aportarían 2500 millones de dólares una
forma de mostrar unidad fuerza y sobre
todo apoyo a esos pequeños bancos el
ferre Republic Bank no olvidemos que es
una entidad financiera regional pequeña
no esto contrasta mucho con la idea el
mensaje que está llegando por parte de
la secretaría del tesoro y por parte del
presidente estadounidense Joe biden que
siguen insistiendo en que la economía es
sólida y nadie nadie ninguno ninguna
persona en este país tiene sus ahorros
en peligro así que de momento la bolsa
hoy ha cerrado en números verdes muy
pendientes de cómo siguen esos futuros
en sus principales indicadores aquí en
el parque New yorkino a la espera de que
mañana vuelvan a abrir Bueno lo decía
mamen yo biden dice que el sistema es
sólido pero realmente cómo está el
sistema bancario en medio de toda
inestabilidad Bueno un reciente reporte
de reveló que en la última semana los
bancos tomaron prestados un total de
164.800 millones de dólares de dos
mecanismos de respaldo que tiene la
reserva Federal de ese país Este es un
mecanismo de respaldo de liquidez para
los bancos y es usado con regularidad
pero en la semana que finalizó este 15
de marzo registró un máximo histórico
frente a la semana anterior los pedidos
de los bancos pasaron de
4.580 millones de dólares a
152.850 en sólo una semana el último
máximo histórico que se podría comparar
es de 111 mil millones de dólares y fue
alcanzado durante la crisis financiera
de 2008 estos datos muestran como 11.900
millones de dólares en préstamos
salieron de este nuevo respaldo de
emergencia de la reserva Federal
conocido como programa de financiación
bancaria a plazo que comenzó a funcionar
justo el domingo tras el colapso del
silicon vallebank Bueno hablamos ahora
del inicio de las reuniones anuales del
banco interamericano de desarrollo el
bid Esto fue en Panamá en este encuentro
se abordan diversos temas desde los
niveles de pobreza en Latinoamérica la
inversión en infraestructura Y por
supuesto Cómo afronta el sistema
financiero de la región este nerviosismo
en la banca mundial entre otros desafíos
nuestro corresponsal en Panamá Oscar
zurbarán nos brinda detalles de este
encuentro
Cuáles son esos principales retos pues
elementos muy representativos de la
región como la formación del capital
humano que limita las posibilidades de
mayor ingreso a las personas también
otros aspectos de carácter global como
el cambio climático la seguridad
alimentaria la energía sostenible la
principal preocupación sigue siendo como
combatir la pobreza en la región según
el banco interamericano de desarrollo
con la pandemia se perdió una década de
esfuerzo en ese sentido y la cifra de
pobres se elevó a 188 millones de
personas en 2022 aproximadamente el 30%
de los habitantes de América Latina de
ese total 106 millones están en pobreza
extrema tras la pandemia ahora una nueva
etapa o una nueva dificultad se presenta
con el entorno actual con alta inflación
altas tasas de interés y los efectos del
colapso de bancos sobre esto conversamos
con Ana María Ibáñez asesora económica
del bit
esos no son buenas noticias para para
nosotros por muchas razones primero
porque el crecimiento va a ser más lento
debido a los desbalances Macro que
tenemos y sobre todo la inflación tan
alta las tasas de interés se han tenido
que subir Y eso implica un frenazo de la
economía no frenazo pero una un como una
desaceleración del crecimiento económico
y la inflación tiene un impacto muy
fuerte sobre la población pero sobre
todo sobre la población pobre y eso es
muy importante y de nuevo eso es otro
choque que se nos está vendiendo encima
y que tenemos que ver cómo afrontamos
para este sábado está prevista la sesión
de reuniones bilaterales entre los
representantes gubernamentales y el
presidente del banco interamericano de
desarrollo ylan goldfine Jorge Pues a
usted muchas gracias por esta ampliación
económica aquí en directo a América lo
invito a que continúe con nosotros que
ya seguimos nosotros en directo
[Música]